[Music]
nowadays it isn't unusual for a big
screen blockbuster to run well over two
hours but even with lengthier runtimes
filmmakers aren't completely free to
include every scene they may envision
for the final product scenes end up on
the cutting room floor of every
blockbuster and others are scrapped
before they're even filmed while the
theatrical film is often all the better
for the cuts it's always interesting to
hear about what might have been in the
case of black panther most fans
certainly had no complaints regarding
the theatrical panel which had a 134
minute runtime still we might have
gotten even more here are the black
panther scenes you didn't see T'Challa
and Nakia go for a run director and
co-writer Ryan Coogler said the movie
constantly changed throughout filming
ultimately resulting in the loss of some
potentially important moments one such
moment would have given viewers a better
glimpse of Wakanda through the eyes of
T'Challa and Nakia as the pair went for
a run
koogler told Digital Spy I was so in
love with Wakanda I wanted to explore it
more in addition to revealing more of
the secretive nation the scene would
have also introduced some important new
characters namely the parents of Nakia
whom the pair would have met at her
childhood home at the end of their
journey
koogler explained think of it as a rocky
style jog or a Muhammad Ali when we were
Kings style Jon however the scene had to
be cut early on due to budgetary
constraints koogler said he was
ultimately okay with the fact that they
never got to shoot the scene considering
it likely would have been cut for time
anyway still it's sad to hear that
viewers won't have a chance to get this
extra glimpse of Wakanda in any DVD X
there's always room for some run action
in the sequel though a Koi a and a lo
flirts black panther has been hailed for
its representation of minority
characters but one cutscene has caused
controversy among some communities the
scene reportedly featured deny guerreras
a koi eight flirting with florence
kazuma's AO
another member of the door of Malaysia
Vanity Fair first called attention to
the scene in April of 2017 when writer
Johanna Robinson said she'd seen a cut
of the scene in which the door of
Malaysia were dancing together in the
scene the koi reportedly looks
flirtatiously at AO telling her you look
good when a o tells her the same thing a
koi a smiles and says I know many were
hopeful that the scene was an indication
that the movie would feature the LGBT
store
from the comic world of Wakanda but
Marvel later crushed those hopes by
saying the comic wasn't used as source
material for the film instead guerreras
Ikoyi is depicted in a relationship with
daniel kaluza's book copy black panther
co-writer Joe Robert Cole was vagin an
interview when asked about the potential
storyline saying he didn't remember the
scene in question but he did add that
there were a few conversations around
different things different directions
with different characters and characters
that we may have consumed by her self
later spoke out on the matter seeming to
say that the scene had existed revealing
the vulture there were a few scenes that
have been cut whatever their reason is I
can't tell you because nobody told me
about whether it's in or not
perhaps that scene will make it to the
home video extras to make up for the
missed opportunity thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]